he says he has to win this game if he
does he will be in the final and here we
go here we go it's a queen's pawn
opening he pushes this ball forward
forusia developing his knight okay the
trompovsky attack this is quite a rare
guest at this top level at the elite
level right tonight developing now and
we will see black push the queen's
bishop porn move it
pick up the pawn on c7 move it to see if
nope he in fact invites white to
actually trade at the bishop for the
night do you think it'll happen no okay
i'm surprised if you traded that night
it would have fixed the pawn structure
drawn out the game into a long battle uh
but okay the pawn's pushing forward now
piece has just been developed i'll tell
you maintaining that extra minute
advantage that's the key at this early
stage for white at least and black is
castled white needs to do the same as
quickly as possible you don't want to
have to worry about king safety earlier
later in the game sorry um okay the
white queen the queen is coming out and
uh
this looks a little bit shaky because
usually the antidote to this is actually
just to ignore the threat to the pawn
and just develop the knight and there it
comes okay so now white has moved to
bishop white is ready to castle the king
away and once that happens it's not easy
for feruzia to get any action against
that king not easy for him to end the
game quickly which he needs to do
ideally and uh artemiev
quite ahead on the clock over a minute
yup over a minute up on the clock
faruzia has attacked the white queen on
the last turn i expect that white knight
on the side now to just capture a pawn
it was such a bad piece he had to go for
this
and he's done a good job so far forza
he's got a decent position out of the
opening rock solid for black in terms of
making a draw i think you would do it in
blitz chess but look at the clock time
it's still a minute and 20 seconds down
now
and more trades have happened
okay white castling away okay and
farouza just really needs to speed up
because he has uh
under
we'll just uh three minutes on the clock
very position on the board though look
at the center it's about to disappear
the ships have left knights have left
once black takes this pawn in the center
it's going to be a symmetrical pawn
structure right but that means there's
yes it's not an exciting position but it
does mean that uh artemia's king is safe
yeah but artemis would love to get a
safe king position but with more tension
left more pieces on the board
for rusia he's heading well towards that
draw already once the black rooks reach
the center of the board black has no
weaknesses black has nothing to worry
about on the board okay the rooks the
rooks have lined up
and uh
now you mentioned your bank of the clock
that's i think that's the only way the
game can be decided in our tamiya's
favor it's just so level okay and uh
what can white even do black's rooks are
ready now
to challenge the center black has a
strong night
any time white moves his night away
we'll just see rook traits anytime
white's queen challenges the black queen
we might just see trades as well and
artemia actually thinking for the first
time um i'm suspecting that the queen
will just move away probably two squares
to the left nope so he kicks back to the
black knight forcing it to a weaker
square but also loosening up the white
king position so pros and cons with that
move that decision are telling me of
trying to create a pin against the black
knight and the black queen black knight
a bit stuck right now okay and uh
ferruja is going directly for the attack
now the pawn on e3 is under threat and
well tamiya kicking back the queen
okay yeah i i think faruzia has
underestimated this last move
okay white's bishop now is ready to step
where that pawn used to sit and now
black has to lose a lot of time with the
queen for russia trying to attack but
getting frustrated and
okay look at him on the camera as well
he's not happy he just looked over to
the clock he's a minute down still and
still no closer to that draw yet okay
and he retreats the queen
and white's knight stepping back
controlling some squares that is sneaky
also the white rook is attacking black's
knight trying to kick that black knight
away from the center and now there's a
question as to how you're going to
defend the pawn and artemiev does it
with his king
unbelievable stuff but it's good it's
decent he's controlling everything he's
controlling squares and farouzia is
looking far more flustered than artemis
artemis ice cold not even moving deadpan
not reacting farouza already
just not comfortable
and not in the flow still more than a
minute down on the clock this time he's
trying to get rid of white's knight the
best defender of the white king but it
still feels slow and white's controlling
all the dark squares yeah that last pawn
push and uh farouza coming up to one
minute and a half
so he has to speed up especially when
you see artemiev has just under three
minutes on the clock and this is why uh
farouja has made a bid to complicate the
position
yeah but it's just looking one sacrifice
sacrifice pawn takes pawn played
yeah and that's just oh yeah frozen is
panicking that last move it shows he's
desperate to try and clarify the
situation he wasn't happy to maneuver
anymore it was costing him too much time
but now white is simply a pawn up and
white queen can go and grab a pawn later
white bishop can jump out attack the
black queen can uh can artemia be even
more bold and attack the knight and the
bishop and yeah he's played it okay yeah
i missed this one i think feruzia missed
this one as well that's a double attack
white's pawn is about to win a piece for
roosevelt he's losing on the board and
the clock he's about to be a piece down
and he's a minute and a half down
just tired after a long day
the situation
it's difficult pressure i think i'll
tell tamiya is too experienced uh in
this site he chose the right opening
not reacting at all he knows he's
completely winning at this point black's
bishop gives itself up the white queen
can just take that bishop and it does
yeah so now a whole bishop up for all
right and uh for regia just 47 seconds
left on the clock
a piece down oh he knows it and
oh that's unfortunately extra piece and
it's a very strong piece as well look at
white's bishop on a great diagonal
all white needs to do is prevent any
traps against the white king any threats
there and okay i'll tell you f again
consumer professional just keeping
things simple pushing pawns forward if
that pawn is captured white will
initiate a queen trade and that will
just make things easy so
again taking more risks because he knows
he's in
trouble this is a neat
very efficient tribe by uh tamiya he
steps forward with his queen and now the
threat is actually to potentially give
some checks and also paul takes pawn in
the air
and
yeah for russia it's hopeless he's
trying something he's trying to just
confuse artemiev by playing on the other
is weaving a mating net on the board i
mean the situation is just hopeless in
fact the computer is telling me mate in
eight yeah that's if black defends the
to the maximum but there's no chance for
russia resigns
it's over for the 18 year old but
vladislav or tamiya he is
so fantastic in this format in his third
tournament in the meltdown champions
chess tour makes it to his second final
he will face magnus carlsen in the final
of the